hi there I'm Priyanka from Google cloud
and today we're talking about prompt
engineering with large language models
whether you're a data scientist
developer marketer or an engineer
productivity is key craft engineering
with large language models such as form
2 can help you be more productive prompt
engineering means using natural language
to command a large language model
through a platform like workspace or
Bart with the right prompts you can have
the model summarize generate and review
content so how do you become a
world-class prompt engineer
tip number one be as specific as
possible always be clear and precise so
the model can understand your request
let's say you want to pay 50 vegan
blueberry muffins if your prompt is give
me a recipe for blueberry muffins the
model won't know that you want 50 or
that they should be vegan you will end
up with some really disappointing
muffins specific prompts lead to better
outputs tip number two utilize
contextual prompts by adding context the
model can better interpret your prompts
in this case telling the model you have
50 vegan guests would help it deliver
better results tip number three provide
examples incorporating examples also
helps is serve as a framework helping
the model understand your request tip
number four experiment with prompts and
personas editing your prompt also known
as tuning is a chance to be creative try
experimenting with keywords sentence
structures and lengths step into the
shoes of the Persona like your favorite
celebrity chef and see the prompt
through their eyes whether you're baking
muffins or writing code Peak
productivity starts with a strong prompt
to learn more about prompt engineering
check out our resources and subscribe to
our Channel until next time happy
prompting